في عالم مستقبلي من
الراحة ، ستكون قادرًا على استدعاء
سيارة لتأتي
لاصطحابك إلى أي مكان تريده.
لقد حصلت على المال الذي
يعمل بشكل جيد ، فانتوم الجديدة كليًا هي
أكبر وأغلى رولز-رويس اليوم
ومجهزة بمسند قوي للقدم
والترفيه في متناول يدك
وسقف يتلألأ مثل النجوم ،
لا يأخذك إلى مكانك فقط  عند الذهاب ،
قد ترغب في قضاء بعض الوقت هنا بينما تقوم
[Music]
Rolls-royce بصنع عدد من
السيارات المصممة لقيادتها من قبل
أصحابها وهي في الواقع رائعة
وهي من بين سياراتي المفضلة
للقيادة ولكن  تم تصميم Phantom على وجه الخصوص
لشخص قد
يرغب في أن يقودها شخص آخر الآن بشكل
رائع مثل هذا أريد أن
أعرف كيف يبدو هذا السائق
آسف لتخيل أن هذه السيارة يمكن أن تنتقل من صفر إلى
60 في ما يزيد قليلاً عن خمس ثوان
هذه السيارة  مقدار هائل من القوة ولكنه موجود
، لذلك لا تشعر
أن السيارة تكافح نوعًا ما من القوة
في خدمة الصفاء ، ولكن في تلك
الأوقات التي تريد فيها
الاسترخاء والاستمتاع بالرحلة بالنسبة لي ، لا يوجد شيء
أفضل من  مقعد مريح في الجزء الخلفي
من رولز رويس
[موسيقى]